You know why I'm happy?
Because design is one of my favorite segments on this show.
And one of the best parts
is getting to work with an incredible designer
who's a friend of the show and Drew Crew member,
Mikel Welch.
(audience applauding)
That's right.
Let's just say,
he makes everything just a little more beautiful.
Take a look.
(upbeat music)
Color,
lighting,
organization,
he's the expert on all things interior design.
You have gray walls and you don't look
like a gray type of girl.
(lady laughs)
Oh, two of them, wow!
There's a lot of bling,
I got to control it all.
(lady laughs)
And just like that, honey, you can feel like Beyonce.
Yes, that's vivalicious.
He's an essential part of Drew's Crew.
Well, hello.
It's Mikel Welch.
His work has been featured in Architectural Digest,
People, and the New York Times.
And he's designed for people like Oprah and Michelle Obama.
Girl, I was about to be
really impressed.
(Drew laughs)
Armed with every tip and trick up his sleeve,
Mikel transforms homes into dream homes.
We have a little situation with the toys.
I had to donate them.
I'm joking.
Oh my gosh!
(gasps)
Mikel sure has designed his way
into our hearts.
Thank you, Mikel.
Thank you.
Always,
I cannot wait 'til our next project.
(Mikel and lady guest laugh)
(audience applauding)
Hi, Mikel.
Hey, friend.
(Drew squeals)
You ready for our next challenge?
Ooh, what is it, what is it?
All right, well, I've always believed
that you don't have to break the bank
to make your space look like a million bucks.
So today we're helping someone from our audience
with her design dilemma
with a few upgrades for her backyard.
Please welcome Belinda Austin.
(audience applauds)
Hey, Belinda.
Hello, hello, hello.
Hi, Belinda, I'm so happy to meet you.
I'm so happy to meet you as well.
Thank you for having me.
Belinda, what bothers you most
about your backyard dilemma?
Okay, so I have a patio
that I have not been able
to do anything with, as you can see.
I've been in my home 17 years,
I need a lot of tips on a budget.
So whatever advice you can give me, I need help.
(Belinda and audience laugh)
Well, you know, Mikel I like to deliver a challenge.
Yes.
And you know,
but I wonder is Belinda alone?
Like do other people let their outdoor spaces kind of not be
realized at all, let alone fully realized?
I think so, I'm gonna throw
my mom under the bus.
Okay.
She's gonna kill me for this,
but I feel like most suburban moms
are plagued with the fact
that you have these huge backyards,
Yes.
but it's all this space.
So you don't really know what to do with it.
So it's kind of like,
how do we chunk it down
Uhuh.
and just start with something small
and then kind of like graduate to other things.
Don't take it all in at the same time.
Okay.
So I'm gonna help you.
Thank you please.
(Mikel and Belinda laugh)
Cause I do have a big yard
and then
the patio.
I like this, and Mikel has some budget-friendly options
to bring some life into your space
with five items
under $50.
Can you say that part again?
That's five items under $50.
(audience applauds)
Under $50.
(Mikel and Belinda laugh)
Let's step outside,
Let's go check it out.
shall we?
(Mikel laughs)
(audience applauds more intensely)
Okay, Mikel,
All right.
what first?
All right,
so you know what, Drew?
So we have a couple of things right here.
The first thing, these right here, these were $13.
(Drew and Belinda gasp)
And let me show you what they really are.
You're gonna get a kick out of this.
These are actually trash cans,
Wow.
trash cans.
All right, speaking of plants and whatnot.
Do you see this beautiful expensive piece of pottery
that's on the table here, Belinda?
Yes, I see.
It was $4.
What?
$4?
$4, $4.
(audience applauds)
$4?
$4,
(Belinda laughs)
$4.
I know, right?
Just a little coat of paint, it's just a ceramic bowl.
You put a little succulent inside of it
and then it looks super expensive.
All right, so I want to give you one more thing.
Do you see anything else on here
that looks kind of like expensive?
Yes, the lazy Suzy.
Okay, well that lazy Susan isn't so lazy.
That is actually a piece of round, like wood round,
and I added a ball bearing to the bottom of it.
So literally, it like it spins, it's like a $6 kit.
You probably have
Take a spin.
like a slice of wood at home.
I do.
Look at that,
Wow.
simple, easy.
Simple, simple, simple,
(audience applauds)
and easy.
(Belinda hums in agreement)
Now there's one other piece here that I absolutely love.
This is probably like the biggest bang for our buck.
So basically I built a lantern
using dollar store picture frames.
What?
So this is literally like
me taking the picture frames, taking out the glass,
and then adding a little bit of hot glue
and then putting it back together.
I mean, that looks full Crate and Barrel,
Yes.
super expensive.
Yeah.
Very, very beautiful.
Yes, Martha Stewart eat your heart out.
Yeah, exactly!
(audience applauds)
Yeah.
Although we love her.
Yes.
(laughs)
But you know, and then the great thing about this,
I even done one of these at my house,
but I turned it into a terrarium where I took the glass
and I just like made sure the glass stayed inside.
But there's so many different ways you can do that
So creative.
so many different ways.
So I had a little bit of budget left
and so I was able to go on Amazon
and also get you a couple of throw pillows
just to kind of like spice things up a little bit.
So you can have a little punch of color.
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
Now,
Thank you for the tips.
(Mikel laughs)
Now Belinda,
I know that your backyard
is also used
for a very important reason.
And I was just wondering
if you feel comfortable sharing that with us.
Oh, absolutely, so 2005,
I lost my youngest brother to a car accident
and every year we celebrate his birthday in August.
So my backyard is the barbecue backyard
where I've had
at least 300 people there one year.
Wow.
Yeah.
And really, our show today is all about you.
And we wanted to give you some love and you know,
we want to make sure that, you know,
you're going home with everything here.
(Belinda gasps)
No way!
Oh, of course.
All of it.
No way!
Obviously.
Oh, thank you!
(Belinda laughs)
(audience applauds)
Thank you, Drew, thank you , Mikel.
Absolutely.
Thank you both so much.
Oh, and we were wondering if we could throw
the party that you are having in honor of your brother.
Absolutely.
Will $5,000 do it?
Oh, no!
Yes.
(Belinda squeals)
(audience applause continuing)
(indistinct)
It sounds like you have a lot of people to entertain.
(Mikel and Belinda laugh)
I was worried
it wasn't enough and you really can't put a price on,
you know, the incredible work that you're doing,
honoring your brother and being an amazing human being
Thank you.
out there in the world.
Thank you so much, oh my gosh, I'm so blessed.
Thank you.
It was an honor from Mikel and...
Thank you, thank you.
But she's gotta get outta here.
She got to put some trash cans...
(audience applauds)
All right, thank you,
thank you guys so much.
(upbeat outro music)